mr. t rose to fame in 1982 with his
appearance in Rocky 3 as Rocky's nemesis
clubber Lang then truly became a star
the following year with his role as ba
Baracus in the hit TV series the a-team
less commonly known by his real name
Lawrence Toro mr. t was ever-present on
TV screens for more than a decade of
domination his star has fallen to some
extent over the years leaving audiences
worldwide wondering does he still pay T
fools
here's the truth about what happened to
mr. t still a pitchman outside of his
acting roles mr. t may be best known as
an advertising pitchman whether he's
Hawking Snickers bars his own cereal or
World of Warcraft his ads have always
been able to get your attention if
nothing else now you can have the
greatest hair in the world of warcraft'
with the mohawk grenade
yeah go I'm leaking whoa crap look good
recently he's appeared in ads for fuse
iced tea in which he makes it clear that
the years have done nothing to affect
his charisma seriously he might be
ageless you can judge for yourself but
he looks exactly the same
rustling Hall of Fame mr. team may have
entered the popular consciousness as a
fictional boxer in 1982 is rocky 3 but
by 1985 the actor behind clubber Lang
had made the leap to real wrestling
serving as tag team partner to Hulk
Hogan versus rowdy roddy piper and mr.
wonderful at the inaugural WrestleMania
this gave rise to a feud which lasted
years between mr. t and Piper who
already had a little respect to the
actor turned wrestler there was no love
in that ring some felt he never paid his
dues as a performer in the ring but when
mr. t was finally inducted into the WWE
Hall of Fame in 2014 he and Piper
finally made peace the old-fashioned way
on Twitter
battling cancer one of the reasons mr. t
decreased his workload was his 1995
cancer diagnosis for t-cell lymphoma he
took on the unwelcome opponent the only
way he knew how aggressively telling
coping with cancer magazine quote can
you imagine that cancer with my name on
it personalized cancer up into a lot
now facing tough opponents but you know
it's time to face my toughest opponent
of all he wrote an as yet unpublished
book on his experience with author Joyce
Brooks called cancer saved my life
cancer ain't for no wimps in which he
said quote if you don't remind me that I
have cancer that I won't remember either
because I'm too busy living it's a
blessing out within uh I'm a cancer
survivor for 12 years you know so I've
been through a lot you know it's been
peaks and valleys you know everyday you
don't feel 100% but I made it through a
whole world's worth of fools in 2011 mr.
t set up shop across the Atlantic for a
show on BBC 3 called world's craziest
fools
we got fooled with change soul we got
fools breaking the law
we got karate fools with fists flying it
feet jumping all over the place a
compendium of ten you believe this clips
captured from cameras around the world
the show ran for 20 episodes before
going off the air in March of 2013 the
show a throwback in the age of YouTube
also used animated segments to
illustrate the antics of more egregious
fools the series looked like it was
going to be a hit but it ended after two
short seasons now I'll celebrate too
early I pity the tool mr. t surprised
both Al Roker and the rest of America in
2015 when he paid a visit to the Today
Show to make an unexpected announcement
a new home improvement show called I
pity the tool Maestri I did carpentry so
I know what I'm doing I'm good with my
hands
well the fighting though building the
DIY Network aired one episode of I pity
the tool and as yet hasn't commented on
whether or not they'll follow up with
more the reason why is the mystery öand
either viewer turn out or something more
behind the scenes is it a pity seems
likely don't be dumb
and hit your thumb mister tweet mr. t
doesn't just pity fools he turns that
pity into positive action through his
uplifting Twitter feed which is full of
good vibes and support informed often by
his born-again Christian faith along
with comments in the world as he sees it
he explained his philosophy during a
eulogy for First Lady Nancy Reagan
saying I'm not a Republican nor my
Democrat I'm just a Christian brother
from the hood trying to do some good
often heard but not seen starting with
his 80s Saturday morning cartoon series
sensibly titled mr. t our mohawked
friend has stayed busy doing voice for
for a variety of projects from cartoon
series like eat the cat Sabrina the
animated series and Pecola
through TV movies like the 1987 version
of Alice Through the Looking Glass and
when she played the Jabberwocky one
little girl he's even been heard of the
big screen of recent years through his
work as the voice of Earl Deveraux in
2009's hit animated feature Cloudy with
a Chance of Meatballs and gamers of a
certain age of no doubt recognized as
dulcet tones in the Lego dimensions game
in which he appeared as his a-team
character ba Baracus some heroes are
simply timeless thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to